- Welcome back everybody
to a Rad Mom Christmas
at the Kelly Clarkson Show.
We are here with a very
rad mama, Michelle Obama!
(audience cheers)
So it's time for a game that
will test what we'd each do
or what we're gonna own
in front of the world,
what we would do as moms
in different difficult
kid scenarios during the holidays.
This is Merry Christmas Mommy.
♪ Merry Christmas mommy ♪
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
I thought- I didn't see
what you were holding.
And it looked like you were
just holding a bottle of wine
or something.
Like, you were like, Merry Christmas mommy
I was like, okay, that's awesome and true.
Here to host and judge is a man who is
neither a mom nor a woman
but I love the light he carries y'all.
He makes me happy.
So I invited him here.
Please welcome, good friend of the show
and host of American Ninja Warrior on NBC
Matt Iseman!
(audience cheers)
(electric music intro)
- Alright, so meet Mrs. Obama
Have y'all ever met before?
- [Matt] No! We haven't.
- I love you!
- Oh my God.
(everyone laughs)
- [Michelle] I love
- I just got my Christmas gift
- I love it. It's crazy.
- [Matt] Well, you know when
you want to come on the show
we have a spot for you.
- Oh no. No, No. I don't think you do.
- She loves you to a point.
- No thank you
- [Kelly] Could you tell
us how this game works?
- So this game is Merry Christmas Mommy
and here's how it's gonna work.
- Okay
- I'm gonna read you a
holiday problem child scenario
- Okay
- Yes
- [Matt] Now you will have to answer
with a solution to that scenario.
You will, you'll take turns going first
but you will both get to answer.
- Okay
- Now, I will be the judge
administering points and ladies
- And your qualifications?
(everyone laughs)
- He has amazing light that he carries.
- [Matt] But right now, I will tell you,
my qualifications are I was
raised by an incredible mom.
(everyone applauds)
- Aww, that's a good one!
- Yeah!
- Yeah, nice comeback
_ That's a good one
- Audience, you're gonna
help me with the answers
- All the guys in the
band were like, yeah!
Okay, go ahead. Sorry.
- [Matt] So Kelly, you're gonna be playing
for the left side of the audience.
- Yes. Yes.
- [Matt] Mrs. Obama, you'll be playing
for the right side of the audience.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Well, jeez!
- And audience, I don't
wanna give anything away,
but I saw the prize they're giving out
and it is awesome.
So are you ready for
Merry Christmas Mommy?
- I'm ready.
- Okay.
- Focus. Focus
- Here is our first scenario.
- Alright
- It's
- [Matt] It's time to
take Christmas pictures
and your 3 year old is screaming
that her dress is itchy
and she refuses to wear tights.
Kelly, we're starting with you.
How do you manage this?
- Did you start with me
because the producers knew
this has happened to me?
(everyone laughs)
Like, I'm not above bribery. Yeah.
I'm like, if you smile for this picture
I will give you whatev-
3 scoops of ice cream.
Bribery.
- That's where I go.
- Bribery is where it goes
And audience?
(audience cheers)
- Yep.
- Not bad. Not bad.
- We're giving that 7
points but now Mrs. Obama,
it is your turn to reply.
- Not bad. Not bad. Bribery
is always a good, easy
- It is easy
- [Michelle] You know, but there's also
the mommy angry face
where you sort of like,
if you don't sit still
- Just the eyes.
- [Michelle] Just the eyes.
- Yeah.
- [Michelle] It's like and
sometimes it could be the
like the underarm pinch.
- Oh yeah.
- You know where it's disguised.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I feel like I should go
sit and time out right now.
- [Michelle] And then you
just instruct the photographer
to move it, let's get
this done, quick and fast.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You know what, mom eyes
- So the underarm pinch
guys, what do you think?
(audience cheers)
- [Matt] 9 points!
- [Kelly] That was good. That was good.
- Right now the score.
Mrs. Obama 9. Kelly 7.
- Thank you for the reminder, Matt.
- Well keep in mind Kelly,
I too am open to bribery.
Alright, here is the next scenario.
Uncle Dave and the host Matt
have had a bit too much eggnog
and Uncle Dave starts
sharing a not suitable
for Christmas story in
front of your children.
- Oh.
- Oh man.
- [Matt] How do you politely
handle this, Mrs. Obama?
- Oh wow. Uncle such and such. Um...
- [Kelly] Yeah, we all have that person.
- [Michelle] Yeah, I know.
I'm trying to, I'm like,
I'm probably, I can, you know you...
I would just start talking over.
- Yep.
- Uncle such and such
and you know, distract the kids.
It's like, oh cookies!
(everyone laughs and cheers)
- [Michelle] Cookies in the kitchen!
- Cookies in the kitchen,
a 10 point answer
- Cookies in the kitchen for everyone!
- See, I now I feel like I'm copying.
I would distract with sugar.
- [Matt] Distract with sugar.
- I would distract the sugar and be like,
you know what's in the other room?
- Right
- Away from this weirdo!
- [Matt] That is an excellent answer.
She delivered it better though.
So you're getting 9 points
and in the end Mrs. Obama,
you won Merry Christmas Mommy!
(audience cheers)
- Whoo! Whoo! Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
- Alright, well it's my show.
- I'm the best
- It's my show and it's Christmas
So and we're all moms, so you know what?
(everyone laughs)
- I love so much
- Hey, kelly
- That means that everyone wins
cause that's what I want.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] So, you don't, you
don't know what you've won yet.
It could be a real crap
gift. I'm just saying.
No, this is awesome. You're
all going on a 3 night trip
to the Grand Cayman Marriott Beach Resort
in the Cayman Islands.
(audience cheers)
(indistinct)
- You're gonna experience
cheap accommodations
with private balconies
and ocean front pool,
complimentary snorkeling
and paddle boarding,
relax at the Botanika
Union spa, love this spa
and indulge in a meal or
hand crafted cocktails
from one of their stylish restaurants.
Y'all are gonna have an amazing
time is what I'm saying.
(audience cheers)
There is more, cause she's special.
So we wanted to make this special.
You're all getting round
trip airfare for two
on Cayman Airways!
(audience cheers)
So you're getting that for free too
- Fly aboard their brand
new state of art jet fleet
with nonstop flights to Grand
Cayman from US gateway cities.
And your Cayman vacation starts
the moment you step aboard
with free 7 Fathoms rum punch
and legendary Cayman kind hospitality.
You're gonna have a good time
and I'm almost proud to
say, almost, not quite
to say that because
Mrs. Obama won the game.
Her photo will be hung
on the chicks of Wall of
Champs who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheers)
Not so excited, but a tiny bit.
A big thank you to Matt
Iseman for hosting y'all!
Then everybody be sure to pick
up Michelle Obama's new book.
It's called The Light We Carry.
It's an amazing book.
Y'all gotta check it out. It's out now.